[موسيقى]
مليون احتجاج مصري
قبل عشر سنوات وأنا بن
ويدمان وزملاؤنا في سي إن إن في القاهرة
غطوا بداية الانتفاضة المصرية ،
نحن في طريقنا إلى ميدان التحرير
هنا
في ذكرى هذا
الحدث التاريخي كان لي محادثة كاشفة وعاطفية
مع  توقف
عن موقفك اليوم ، وكنت
هناك معًا ،
إنه أمر محبط للغاية ،
وأنا أعلم أنه بعد مرور 10 سنوات لم نصل إلى أي مكان
حيث يجب أن نكون في الواقع ،
يمكنك أن تجادل وستكون على حق في أن الأمر أسوأ
الآن ما هو  أفكارك الآن بعد
عشر سنوات هذه ذكرى أه صعبة جدًا
لأي شخص أه كان هناك
غطى الحديث وعاش
وشارك
أه في هذه الثورة ما زلت أحب أن
أسميها ثورة
كان الناس مرهقين نوعًا من جيل الشباب
بشكل متزايد  كان ذكيًا ومثقفًا جيدًا
وطموحًا مرهقًا من هذه الديكتاتورية
الدكتاتورية المسنة مثل ربما في عهد حسني
مبارك
لرؤية هذا التدفق الذي انتهى
في البداية في  كان مساء الخامس والعشرين من يناير
مبهجًا
يفوق خيال الكثيرين أعتقد أن
الناس
اكتشفوا قوة
الاحتجاج وخلال تلك الأيام الصعبة أه
عندما كنا
نغطي الانتفاضة أه كانت هناك
محاولة من بعض بلطجية الحكومة  لإسكات
الصحفيين في بعض الحالات كانوا عنيفين
معهم ، قيل لي إن
المشي لا تقل في أم
في ميدان تايوان لقد شعرت
بالخوف قليلاً وأنا أتذكر وأنا أنت وأنا
وأندرسون كوبر في  الوقت
المحصن في هذا المكتب لأن
كل هذه العصابات البلطجية المخيفة
كانت نوعًا ما كانت
تستهدف الصحفيين الغربيين في
ذلك الوقت ،
تلقيت رسالة أه أن الولايات المتحدة
تطلب من جميع
مواطنيها مغادرة البلاد وبالطبع
صعوبة
إن تغطية الوضع في مصر في ذلك
الوقت
هو أنك لا تقوم فقط بتغطية
القصة التي تعيشها القصة
بدأت أعتقد أن عائلتي تعيش عائلتي
كما تعلمون  بعيدًا عن هنا في
حي بجوار
أكبر سجن في مصر
وكانت هناك سلسلة من عمليات الهروب من السجون
ولا تمنعك من معرفة أنه سيكون لديك
سجناء يتجمعون في جميع أنحاء هذا
الحي المزدهر
حيث لدي زوجة وثلاثة أطفال
و  وهكذا حقًا كانت تلك الفترة التي كانت 18
يومًا
مؤلمة لأنني كنت مضطرًا
إلى الموازنة بين
مسؤوليات واجباتي المهنية
واهتماماتي
واهتمامي العميق أه بعائلتي وهي القصة التي
لا تزال عاطفياً
هي التي لها تأثير أكبر
عليك اليوم  إنها مصر ، أعني أن هناك شيئًا
عن ذلك ، لقد عشت فيه كنت أذهب إلى
الجامعة في القاهرة في
أوائل الثمانينيات ، هل يمكنني أولاً أن أكون هناك في
مهمتين أه يبلغ مجموعها 12
عامًا 11 عامًا قابلت زوجتي الجميلة ياسمين
في
القاهرة أه تربى أطفالي  الكثير من
حياتهم
أه في القاهرة ، لذلك رأيت كل ذلك ،
حسنًا ، سيئًا ، قبيحًا ، مرعب
الأشياء المدهشة التي
تعيد إيمانك
بالحياة ، هل سبق لك أن تعرضت لموقف ما
هل قررت عمدا ألا
تشاهد الفيديو أو تنظر إلى صورة
هناك على
ما يبدو لدي بعض الأفلام الرائعة عن
الثورة المصرية مثل لا أستطيع أن
لا أستطيع مشاهدتها.
قرأت كتبًا قرأت كتبًا جيدة
عن الثورة المصرية
التي كنت تعرف صفحاتها في بعض الأحيان
فقط نوعًا ما
شعرت وكأنني كنت مستغرقة في
كتاب الأفلام التي لا أستطيع مشاهدتها ، أعني أنني
لا
أعرف أنني لا أعرف  أنا لا أحب العنف ،
أعني أنه يجب علي
تغطيته لأن وظيفتي هناك سبب
للأمل
اليوم لا أعلم أننا نمر
بفترة صعبة للغاية في الوقت الحالي ، أنا
فقط لا أعتقد
أن الظلم موجود  دائم
سواء كان في مصر أو في سوريا العراق
أو
لبنان حيث لا يمكن أن يستمر إلى الأبد
[موسيقى]